this video is brought to you by manscape
comm if you've been watching just King
news for a while you know we are huge
fans of manscaped this is growing but
not down there it's a manscape I've seen
it they are the only men's brand that
are dedicated to below the waist
grooming and hygiene so if you ever felt
like your dicks too small like me when
you shave off the hair you honestly add
like a good two inches and you're like
oh [ __ ] and it even surprised Gio the
shoe is like what oh my duh has been
that big homie it just helps with the
visuals yeah cuz when you have a puffy
cloud that's blocking a beautiful cliff
what ends up happening is the cliff
looks smaller
yep and this is why we recommend the
lawnmower 3.0 body trimmer by manscape
so they have a 7000 RPM motor with quiet
stoke technology and it also has a built
in LED light for closer more precise
trim PBC we're going I like that part
battery lasts 90 minutes and it's also
cordless and waterproof and you can do
it in the shower we encourage you guys
to check out the perfect package
essentials kit which includes the lawn
mower 3.0 trimmer plus everything you
see here so after you shave you gotta
use some ball toner it's gonna refresh
eyes it's it revives it's refreshing and
some ball deodorizer it's ball deodorant
actually for anti chafing yes if you
have do you can take care of it
my favorite thing is this clip right
here because if you want to get a really
close trim then you use this but then
sometimes you got to be really careful
so I use I mean somebody just wanna do a
really quick shave we didn't want to pay
attention so I put this one on and I
actually can get a decent shave without
having to worry to cut myself if you
order the perfect essential kitten now
you also get two additional gifts you'll
get the manscaped anti chafing boxers
and also the shed travel bag simply
visit mass capcom and enter our code JK
news to get a 20% discount free shipping
plus two free gifts go ahead and check
out that link and it is
scription box below we have it there
it's all easy and simple to follow you
just click and buy and your boss well
thank you thank you very much
[Music]
have you guys came across that photo
yeah this is some crazy [ __ ] yeah got
the guys though I know that's awesome it
was just super sad the store right so to
fill you guys in in case you don't know
you've been living under a rock
his name was Ahmad he was 25 years old
when he was jogging around his
neighborhood in Georgia and he just got
gunned down by this father and son
George and Travis so why do they look
like
the kind of people that you would expect
yeah right now there was a movie casting
for races white guys like oh yeah they
fit the bill like I've never looked at
their picture to just now I'm like yeah
that's right like if you remove the hood
this is wonder I'll be watching the
video y'all wanna one I never saw the
video I never brought myself around I
watched it
but there's supposed to be a longer
video out there yeah we had the short
one is a long one do we know I think
it's the short one if it if it starts
with him running halfway going behind
the car there's supposed to be another
one that's the full thing and I've been
trying like to look for but I can't find
it we've found meaning to be found
another video that also offers a
different kind of story - yeah I've been
looking at all different angles that
really offers another story it's just
we'll get there but yeah yeah yeah okay
so warning this video is pretty graphic
nothing's worked out yeah play it I mean
if you always cut it out after if
anything okay well uh you don't really
see it yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you've
just imagined it but just the way that
the guys are on our truck it just looks
like they're just out huntin trouble
yeah yeah
and this is recorded by their friend
that's oh really yeah
oh really cuz when I was reading the
article they didn't know who turned it
in it's the one person it supposed to be
the guide with them it's a third person
with them the two guys yeah this part oh
my god it's [ __ ] so sad in fact the
guys just on that in the truck bed like
they're waiting for him yeah they're
calling like the mayor of Elena's little
lynching it's a modern day lynching yes
yeah so okay so the reason why or like
according to Travis and joerger II they
said that they had recognized a mod as
being one of the being a guy that has
been involved in a lot of break-ins know
their story their side of the story is
right there was someone in that area
that was breaking into homes or whatever
yeah and he matched the description of
someone who was recently in one of their
neighbours houses saying that there have
no there haven't been any reports of
break-ins yeah but this is their story
right and so because I read up on this
and I was just like how did this all
kind of come to be the guy that's
recording is their buddy like when
what's his name Travis yeah this is the
younger or the son who's the GU the
runner am on a mod okay so when a mod
passed their house they called their
buddy as backup and so they went ahead
they were in front and in the the third
person who's following them with the
camera that's their friend that's that's
that that's why you see him running up
to the car and they're trying to stop
him to talk to him so the the part
that's kind of weird to me as he runs
- the guy with the gun and then he gets
shot so that place is all super blurry
right and the camera moves away and it
moves away you don't know what the
hell's going on yeah but that's the
story of the two KKK guys I just made
that up
they're not King okay I don't know but
the two guys that were on the two white
guys yeah they're their story was there
was a man going around that matched a
description and so they wanted to stop
him and confront him which i think is
[ __ ] crazy
cops yeah why are you taking it into
your own hands but also they are not the
cops but they're deeply connected to the
judicial system they're well Gregory
used to be
he's a former all right right the dad
one former police officer so he took it
into his own cop hand that the whole
case had to be passed through three das
yeah because the the first two they
recused that is it yeah so two hundred
their home he actually worked in their
office yeah so that there was Sunday
right uh I think the dad because he was
an investigator but I thought the son
work in the courthouse or something -
yeah but so two of them recuse
themselves and then after this thing
became public and in the third DA like
was like what the [ __ ] do I do then
that's when they he pass it on to the
FBI yeah or the G GBI yeah in Georgia
Bureau you know yeah it's like it's all
[ __ ] up but the guys they weren't
arrested for it because Deut this is
back in February right
no they just yeah it was self-defense
two months ago this happened February
23rd this is in Georgia two months and a
whole bunch of social media posting it
took social media after the video going
public and the a radio station released
it right [ __ ] is nuts
the whole time I was just like oh man
wanted to run away why did you run
towards I mean like I don't know I don't
think we see enough to like say that
like but I replayed that and I was just
hoping that he would run away from that
truck if I saw guys with guns I would
have [ __ ] run away but he
toward them or maybe like we also don't
hear what they're saying like slightly
here a little bit of yelling but hey I'm
not the guy you're looking for or
something you know like you like cuz
most people don't think they're gonna
get shot by people yeah if I see guys
with guns I'm running the other way man
yeah but yeah I don't know I didn't hear
the yelling what they were like get get
over here or else right and he gets over
there with it like [ __ ] if I'm gonna get
shot I guess I'm gonna be shy running
away because he held onto the gun and
started wrestling with them what if
someone has a gun and they're with
enough foot of you I think it's like
okay well you have two options fight off
the gun or run away and I think he you
know he's like to keep my best option
here is to get the gun away from the guy
we've seen the first shot was through
his hand oh my gosh I'm through the hand
yeah
so he's like he was close because they
were in front of the truck so all that
[ __ ] just went down like in front of the
truck so it's kind of hard to tell what
the [ __ ] went down I mean just hear the
sounds pop we always talked about how
like you have no idea what the [ __ ] I
do until what happens right yeah like
like Bart got slapped in the face by a
girl I had some convention and then he
just walked away yeah so like you yeah
and then you don't know if the guys
telling him hey come here and he's
running toward him cuz he told him come
here exactly and then you know the
[ __ ] been running down the road
the entire time was quote horses coming
towards you [ __ ] and I think what a mod
people were saying that he was just
jogging around the neighborhood or
whatever and then the counter-argument
to that is why is the man jogging in
boots and shorts
he's wearing boots that yeah or like if
you watched the footage it just doesn't
seem like he's in jogging attire we
didn't know that he's in robbing a tire
well what is robbing entire boot they
look like hi tubs
maybe this commentators who think it's
boots and they're like digital point out
whatever just basketball cuz I was
reading all kinds of different angles to
it like and why did they not get [ __ ]
arrested because that was the weirdest
thing to me
not only that the law there they have a
stand-your-ground law but that's not on
their property yeah doesn't happen
that's a that's a castle law stand your
ground law you don't have to be on your
property anywhere yes these people down
if no no if someone's like you're armed
right and if someone is coming toward
you you can shoot them the park in front
of his running path please I know
exactly they're right in his running
path this course that Georgia's Stand
Your Ground law does not allow people to
be lying in wait we don't believe that
this was even arguably self-defense or a
citizen's arrest but even under their
sort of peculiar theory they can't set a
trap but that is the gray area that
they're claiming me can't stop someone
in the middle of the road hop out with
guns create a dangerous situation
availed themselves of stand your ground
or self-defense
so my point no no so my point is I'm not
talking about the legality that's what
their side of the argument they're using
this in in a way to get away right so
that's what they're quoting yes so the
same thing with the burglar sorry
they're just trying to use that as a way
to get away exactly but we don't know
what really went on cuz it's so [ __ ]
crazy I mean like so so the the the main
story is they're saying that these guys
saw a black man in the neighbor
neighborhood right and they just wanted
to kill for me in the master description
but then they find out that there really
has been no reports right so they set up
that roadblock or whatever just to
murder this dude and hunt him down so
that's that's kind of like once one
story but another story is right in the
middle where people are like oh what if
there was a guy that's been going around
robbing houses and he just they just
wanted to make a citizen's arrest
because of the cop nature of the of the
dad was in his training right I don't
know if this was a true aria but it's
like you hear him being like oh there's
a guy breaking into this house like
right now and then he goes oh sure he
just took our foot you just passed my
house right now he goes there he goes
and you just you just hear them go after
him
yeah that's another one I heard about
too is that they were saying
that it was happening like firsthand
like there's footage of this guy in in
someone's garage that's what they're
investigating now is that there's
footage of him in like construction but
they're saying that okay so the owner of
an under-construction home he was listed
as a victim in a police incident report
saying that his surveillance system
captured at least four short clips of a
man who appeared to be Ahmad and coming
onto his property on that same day and
so he was saying that the most that it
showed like any sort of crime being
committed is trespassing so in in the
more than seven weeks before the
shooting there were there was only one
burglary report in the neighborhood and
that was a gun a handgun had been taken
out from an unlocked car in front of
these guys Wow
yeah so there the problem well I mean
maybe a handgun in an unlocked car in
front of their house um yeah I mean I
got to read more into it but the crazy
thing that went down is is you clearly
saw the corruption in that little town
because they're so hooked up that they
could literally kill a dude and get away
with it
I mean in broad daylight dudes all
certainly not earn themselves in right
they confidently were like hey we did
this thing alright we're free to go now
by the way about it we're friends right
we're all cops together they'd probably
have to love to protect the community
more you know like for them the second
they see another black person come
through they probably what it does the
same thing they should have at least
like got manslaughter or something I
don't know at least been taken in the
first time when I'm instigated
investigate a little bit nothing
happened until it became a social media
outcry a mod have a prior record or
anything he has some and that's what
they're trying to do is is every single
time whenever something like this
happens in like in the news all of a
sudden it's like this one person had
weed on them three years ago and it's
like all right you're gonna
this guy just because and he's the
victim and he was shot it you know but
that I guess like in terms of statistics
people that have commit crimes even once
it's like it's like 70 percent is
extremely high that they will do it
again so that's why it it leaned it
makes people investigators look that
much more into the trespassing footage
and to see it helps it helps the
investigators go okay should I
investigate this more should I ask the
people around this property to see if
they have anyone else has any footage
but if it's squeaky clean record it's
highly unlikely that someone would have
committed a crime and trespass so
instead of asking 12 extra neighbors it
gives the it points the detectives in
the right direction okay I can avoid my
police work here I'll put my police work
and prior convictions help in types of
crimes so if you had a burglary
conviction right you're gonna likely
you're you're most likely gonna look at
burglaries like if this guy has been
caught for burglary then he's probably
doing that you're not looking for armed
robbery you're not looking for
carjacking you're gonna probably narrow
your search what
but what Bart is doing is more so look
doing the police work I think what
you're talking about is the PR work
right so it's not grabbing some way that
the oftentimes whenever things like this
happened the media will focus depending
on who they are what part of the
characteristic to bring out so so
there's two sides of the news point
that's not I'm talking about the police
in the policing part right so there's
two sides of the coin right there's a
liberal narrative and there's gonna be a
conservative narrative there's gonna be
a white narrative and there's gonna be a
black narrative they're so polarizing
right and for me I just want to know
what the [ __ ] went truth
yeah truth narrative like was it some
racist dudes that just want to blast the
black guy for no reason that's what it
looks like yeah that's what it looks
like I just found this other article
that they're saying that one of the men
accused of shooting Ahmad was involved
in a previous prosecution of him and
apparently the prosecution like he was
investigating a mod because he
he had previously he was he allegedly
brought a gun to a 2013 highschool
basketball game when he was 19 and that
said it seemed and then apparently that
he had been arrested on shoplifting
charge yeah so those so what happened
with that case I don't know as much as
I've been because in if it's just
allegedly then it's like so nothing else
actually matter what what those two guys
did was completely the incorrect way to
do it oh yeah absolutely
yeah regardless of prior conviction what
the [ __ ] like like if you're not if
you're off-duty right and you're you're
civilian now like why is it why are you
the [ __ ] law like why the [ __ ] are
you the guy parking your damn car and
obstructing like a person from and then
you're the you're the [ __ ] toll-like
troll now like that then yeah that
people have to answer to yeah even if
you were wearing a badge even if you
were in a patrol car had a badge on I
don't think you can be [ __ ] shooting
a [ __ ] guy running on the side of the
street like that you know the kind of
the cool thing is like this is the one
time where both like Democrats
Republicans conservative liberal like
they all came together was like this is
[ __ ] up the way this happened yeah
people that you would not expect like
this one especially like the gun
community all of them would say more
conservative they're like this guy was
hunted down and like killed like an
animal you know and they're like this is
against how you proceed with any of
these things yeah that's that's um
that's beyond vigilante that's this is
some [ __ ] assassination [ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]